[Música]
el gobierno peruano le pidió a la
compañía repsol que repare el daño
causado por el derrame de petróleo en la
costa de la provincia de callao el crudo
está afectando la vida marina en dos
áreas naturales protegidas analizamos en
esta emisión
alrededor de 1200 policías ocuparon la
favela de jacarezinho en río de janeiro
en el marco de un nuevo proyecto de
pacificación del gobierno regional que
planea retomar el control de varias de
esas zonas que están bajo el dominio de
narcotraficantes y milicias
parapoliciales tenemos información desde
brasil
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson se negó a renunciar por las
fiestas realizadas durante la pandemia
en su residencia oficial ante la presión
anunció que el 27 de enero serán
levantadas la mayoría de las
restricciones por kobe 19 en inglaterra
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en perú donde
el gobierno le exigió a la multinacional
repsol que repare el daño causado tras
el derrame de petróleo en la costa de la
provincia de callao repsol opera la
refinería la pampilla donde el sábado se
produjo el vertimiento tras el inusual
oleaje producido por la erupción
submarina y posterior tsunami en tonga
en el pacífico sur el ejecutivo de pedro
castillo afirmó que el crudo está
poniendo en peligro la flora y la fauna
en dos áreas protegidas
para analizar esta información
conectamos con fabiola muñoz exministra
de ambientes de perú abogada y
coordinadora de la coalición por una
producción sostenible bienvenida
france24 hasta qué punto repsol es
responsable por el derrame de petróleo
de petróleo al haberse producido por el
oleaje causado por un fenómeno natural
bueno muchas gracias por la oportunidad
aquí tenemos que analizar dos momentos
el primer momento es cómo se produjo las
circunstancias en las que se produjo
este derrame y ahí se está haciendo la
investigación la empresa dice que desde
el día anterior están haciendo la
descarga y que consultaron si existía
alguna alerta a raíz de la situación de
tonga no tuvieron información al
respecto de una alerta de su también por
lo tanto continuaron con el proceso y
tuvieron la diligencia debida eso es lo
que hay que investigar
porque si de repente pudieron haber
tomado la decisión de parar la descarga
esto no se hubiera producido entonces
pues es un primer elemento para la
investigación el segundo elemento es lo
que sea por negligencia o sea realmente
por un hecho fortuito se produjo este
derrame entonces la empresa tiene que
activar inmediatamente lo que se llaman
los protocolos de contingencia y eso
implica que acciones tiene que tomar
para remediar esta situación
lo primero es comunicar efectivamente y
ahí es donde creemos que no
necesariamente la comunicación ha sido
lo más rápida posible ni lo más
transparente posible un segundo elemento
es tomar acción para limitar el impacto
ahí la empresa ha manifestado que ha
puesto un cerco digamos para controlar
que esto no se siga expandiendo los
terceros son las operaciones para el
recojo del crudo y sacarlo del agua y
evitar que siga teniendo siga afectando
a la flora y la fauna lo siguiente es
identificar toda la fauna silvestre que
se pueda tratar de rescatar tratar con
los veterinarios de hacer las
operaciones de limpieza de las aves de
los lobos
recordemos que efectivamente son dos
áreas naturales protegidas donde tenemos
fauna silvestre importante la gran
biodiversidad
y finalmente es toda la parte de la
operación de limpieza en el terreno de
la costa de la playa y ahí es donde le
pedimos no cierto existimos en realidad
como ciudadanos a la empresa que ponga
la mayor diligencia el mayor sentido de
urgencia sobre esta situación
bueno señora muñoz a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france 24
ahora vamos a estar la ciudad brasileña
de río de janeiro donde 1200 policías
ocuparon las calles de la favela de
jacarezinho y de otra en la zona que
están bajo el control de grupos de
narcotraficantes y organizaciones
parapoliciales el operativo hace parte
de una ópera una macrooperación del
gobierno local valeria saccone
corresponsal de france 24 nos dio más
detalles
14 años después del intento fallido de
pacificar las favelas de río de janeiro
el gobierno local lanza una nueva
operación llamada ciudad integrada con
el objetivo de reducir la violencia en
esos barrios de la ciudad
la operación arrancaba esta madrugada
con un dispositivo de 1200 agentes que
han entrado en la favela de jacarezinho
donde en mayo del año pasado se
registraba la mayor masacre policial de
la extendería con un saldo de 28
residentes muertos esta mañana no ha
habido enfrentamientos armados porque
según nos han contado habitantes de esta
favela los narcotraficantes que
controlan este territorio ya sabían de
esta operación prefirieron salir de
noche para evitar enfrentamientos
armados además la policía también ha
entrado en otras favelas de la zona
oeste de río de janeiro llamada moussem
a donde la presencia de los grupos
paramilitares conocidos como milicias es
muy fuerte el objetivo del gobierno es
ahora ocupar unas favelas estratégicas
patrullar y disputar el territorio a eso
de narco sin embargo muchos habitantes
con los que hemos hablado hoy temen que
sea otra operación de maquillaje
político antes de las elecciones de este
año y temen que no se resuelva nada como
aconteció con las unidades de la policía
pacificadora que fueron desmanteladas
después de los juegos olímpicos eso sí
ellos temen que de nuevo haya un
abordaje agresivo con los habitantes de
las favelas y que se criminalice una
población que en su mayoría es
constituida por trabajadores
en otras noticias en alemania avanza un
tercer juicio contra perpetradores de
crímenes de lesa humanidad por la guerra
en siria el médico a la musa de 36 años
es sospechoso de haber torturado a
opositores de bashar al-assad en un
hospital militar andrés granadillo nos
cuenta más
acusado de crímenes de lesa humanidad es
el juicio contra este médico sirio quien
enfrenta cargos por torturar a
prisioneros civiles que estaban en
contra del gobierno de bachar al asad
se les acusa de torturar a 18 presos en
un hospital militar y también en una de
las prisiones del servicio secreto y de
causar graves daños físicos y mentales a
las víctimas
en un caso se le acusa de administrar
una inyección letal en dos casos se le
señala de intentar esterilizar a los
hombres y jádson venganza sus campos
racing a la m llegó a alemania en 2015
para trabajar como médico hasta que fue
detenido en junio de 2020 desde entonces
se encuentra en prisión preventiva la
semana pasada la corte alemana condenó
al ex oficial de inteligencia
anual razlan a cadena perpetua por
delitos contra la humanidad fue acusado
de asesinar a 27 prisioneros y torturan
al menos a otros 4000 entre 2011 y 2012
en la prisión al khatib en la más con
los fiscales alemanes se valen de leyes
de jurisdicción universal para juzgar
estos casos
los crímenes de lesa humanidad pueden
ser juzgados en todo el mundo y también
procesados entonces es irrelevante qué
nacionalidad tiene el acusado y en qué
país se cometieron los crímenes
se basa en el principio de la
solidaridad internacional
alemania no actúa en interés propio sino
en nombre de la comunidad de naciones
de bachar el gobierno de bashar al-assad
llega a las torturas contra prisioneros
pese a denuncias de organizaciones como
amnistía internacional que documentaron
esta práctica de manera sistemática
desde 2011 en diez años el conflicto en
siria deja al menos 500.000 muertos y 66
millones de personas desplazadas y en el
exilio
pese a la creciente presión en su contra
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson se negó a renunciar tras la
polémica por las fiestas celebradas en
su residencia oficial durante la
pandemia cada vez son más las voces que
piden su dimisión e incluso un diputado
de su partido se cambió a la oposición
laborista por rechazo a su gestión en
medio del escándalo el funcionario
anunció una flexibilización de las
restricciones a partir del 27 de enero
ya no será obligatorio presentar el
carnet de vacunación ni portar
mascarilla en inglaterra
el año pasado su majestad estaba sola en
el funeral del hombre con el que estuvo
casada durante 73 años en la vigilia de
ese funeral se llenó una maleta con
alcohol y se llevó a downing street
donde tocó un dj y el personal festejo
hasta tarde
teniendo en cuenta que el primer
ministro dictó las normas porque creen
que esta nueva defensa va a funcionar es
que
seamos absolutamente claros el honorable
caballero sigue haciendo preguntas que
sabe que serán abordadas en su totalidad
por la investigación está perdiendo el
tiempo de la cámara y el tiempo de la
gente
es todo por el momento en france 24
feliz tarde para todos
[Música]